foreign
we're going to start off this hour with
Luke in Fort Wayne Indiana hi Luke
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call it's
an honor honor to speak with you sir how
can we help
um so I was calling to get some advice
um because I'm getting married in six
months and moving out of home for my
parents and
I'm wondering what you would advise is
kind of like a
uh nest egg or just a small it feels
like I should have some money set aside
to pay for you know like furniture and
you know the deposit and things like
that
do you have an emergency fund right now
I do I have a thousand dollars I'm on
baby step two
wonderful
well Dave I am curious how much beyond
the deposit so you have your deposit for
the apartment
I mean if you're on baby step two
I'm thinking pretty cheap but Dave
what's your take yeah you need to well I
mean basically it's not do you need more
than a thousand dollars in savings uh
that's not the question uh the question
is how you're going to fund the setup
and um show you what do you make what's
your income
50 000. okay and so you've got the money
coming in you don't have any overhead to
mount anything right
correct yeah so you're going to slow
down your debt snowball enough to cover
your deposits to get your utilities set
up to buy a garage sale couch
and a Craigslist kitchen table
and get some dishes while you're at that
garage sale I'll show you got something
to eat off of and uh you know just set
the place up cheap and then uh then you
can upgrade from there as you go along
towards the marriage date and and with
the uh with the wedding gifts as well
that'll help put a little nicer things
in the cabinets right
um get you a toaster and whatever else
you got to have there right so uh you
know but but the big things you're gonna
have to do is avoid just go retail you
know spend twelve thousand dollars on
furniture you're not going to do that
you don't have twelve thousand dollars
whatever yeah I think you really need to
go in with like a Frugal mindset right
rather than asking the question like how
much you know should I have in a typical
scenario it's like you know how cheap
can we do this in a way that we still
get to live in a place that's not you
know a terrible spot but how can we save
the most money in this situation I mean
you know talk to the apartment complex
find out what your deposit is you know
what that you know what that is you know
what your first month rent is they're
all going to be due up front you also
got to check with the utility companies
find out exactly what those are those
are fixed numbers and then just give
yourself a used furniture budget and
just get in there and start with nothing
and start you know super super super
cheap and keep working your debt
snowball uh all the while who's paying
for the wedding
my family I'm paying for a little bit of
it I've already paid for the honeymoon
um but the the wedding isn't much of an
expense I'd say less than probably five
hundred dollars that's what I'll pay how
much debt do you all have
uh so I only have like ten thousand uh
but my fiance has about 80 000 so we
have ninety thousand well there's not a
Wii yet after you're married we have
ninety thousand but yeah right now she's
paying hers you're paying yours until
the actual wedding occurs and then we
combine everything and we attack from
there but I mean the two of you can go
shop for a garage sale couch
um together and you're you're buying it
but you're both going to end up sitting
on it
um certainly after marriage and so go
pick some of these things out have an
adventure with this stuff and you know
Sharon and I did this stuff Luke I mean
we got married it was uh if you go to
the rich end of town there are people
that will put a eight thousand dollar
nine thousand dollar leather couch out
on their uh in their garage sale for for
a hundred bucks because they've got to
get out of the way literally the kitchen
table we still use to this day I got for
free off Craigslist from a lady in the
rich part of town who just didn't want
it yeah I was trying to get rid of it it
was literally fully wood like a fourteen
hundred dollar table that she didn't
want to take the time to take somewhere
else so I was like I'll take it and I
just it does make me think of that
season when we were first you know
married when I was first getting out in
the world even with Apartments I would
literally just refresh apartment
websites trying to find deals so I I had
my eyes set on this really nice
apartment that was it was I'm gonna date
myself a little in Nashville it was 900
a month and I was like I cannot afford
that I kept refreshing keep refreshing
one time it refreshed and they said they
had a special for 550 a month and I
jumped on it I went in that day so it's
like I was just so hungry to find
something that I could afford that it
was less about you know like what's the
typical apartment price can I afford
that I was aggressive in trying to find
the best deal turns the whole thing into
a game yeah it's actually
how cheap can we do this and how how
great a deal can we get what kind of
bargain can we get and you know that's
how you get started and and the good
news is is that this is not a forever
couch no unless you get a really nice
one like our kitchen now it's still not
forever cash because it's not your couch
I mean it's just it's just a it's a
hundred dollar thing to sit on right or
a 50 thing to sit on that's all it is
and you're gonna you're gonna upgrade
later and you're gonna upgrade later and
you know you're gonna move and you're
gonna do all kinds of stuff and so it's
you know two years from now none of this
will still be there you will have moved
on now in your case you've kept the
table because it was a very cool table
to start with but yeah so but the uh but
I'm just saying I don't we don't have
any of that furniture 40 years later
that we started with I'm just telling
you not one stick of it that I'm aware
of so uh but that you know it's okay
it's just a place to start so the point
is you don't need a bigger emergency
fund how much do I need to have in
savings no you just need a budget to
move in that encompasses your deposits
and a little bit of setup costs for
Furnishings uh from the garage sale and
the rich people into town